the rsd we've been created more like
what i would call like Swift boats where
we're able to change directions nimbly
and quickly in traditional school
systems have been like luxury liners if
you want to turn that thing around it
takes forever and a day I'm Catherine
manga award with reason TV and we're
here at the national summit on education
reform with patrick joe' bard who is the
superintendent of the louisiana recovery
school district thank you for joining us
thank you for having me you were
horribly unlucky and also very lucky to
have a weather disaster which kind of
kicked off what happened in you in
norleans and in Louisiana more generally
I'm for people who don't know the story
tell me the story of how the recovery
school district exists the recovery
school district exists in 2003 our
legislature actually passed the law that
said the state would be able to
intervene in chronically underperforming
schools and then in 2005 you know
catastrophe occurred a disaster just
beyond our wildest imagination and
basically wiped the city of New Orleans
out just for a period of time and so in
2005 after the storm we had a special
legislative session where the
legislature at that time felt that it
was important to use this as an
opportunity to really try to transform
the education landscape in the water
before the stone we saw a public school
system that was really in total
dysfunction and disarray so much so that
you know the valedictorian of one of the
high schools wasn't able to pass a state
minimum skills assessment test in order
to earn her diploma and so Katrina
literally and figuratively washed away
many of the institutional barriers that
had prevented us from even imagining
that we could begin to make some
systemic changes to this school system
so I think one element of what you do
and what has helped kind of improve
schools really anywhere in the country
is the closing of bad schools right
that's something that it's never popular
even when a school is bad you know still
parents are you do it's my school
sometimes people have kind of a feeling
of ownership and of course teachers
unions tend to not like it can you tell
me about some schools that you
closed and why sure one in particular
was a school last year at this time that
we made a decision to close it was
Benjamin Mays prep school so charter
school that had been in existence for
five years they were coming up on their
renewal for their contract and it didn't
meet any of the bars as far as like the
criteria so you have to have like
different areas of academic achievement
financial solvency and for us it was a
matter of saying you know we went to
parents and talk to them and parents
were upset about the school closing but
it was a classic example of what some
have coined the happy bad school so our
parents might have been engaged and the
kids engaged and they felt good kids
weren't reading on level they weren't
moving as their cohorts around the city
were moving in other schools and so it
was us to be able to say look your kids
deserve better we can still make it a
happy school but it can be a good school
and with that we close the school there
was some you know complaints and people
upset but those kids who then took us up
on the offer and those families to get
them into high-performing schools over
eighty five percent of the parents that
took advantage of it got into a higher
performing school that very next year
and so it works so we have to try to
balance and be sensitive to community
concerns but at the end of the day we
value having students in higher quality
environments we're going to do
everything we can within the law to
ensure that that happens do you see
other places where there's kind of a
concern that as you know as the the
Charter systems kind of regular eyes and
as people just get used to the status
quo that there might just be kind of a
creepy creeping ree centralization I
mean that's sort of a natural tendency
of bureaucracies what do you do to
prevent that yeah I think I think a
couple of things will happen to prevent
that one our charters will remind us of
their autonomy and in really you know
and say hey this might be an
infringement I think it would keep us
like on our toes to not become the
bureaucracies that some of us have come
to [ __ ] but I think it's one of those
things where the rsd we've been created
more like what i will call like Swift
boats where we're able to change
directions nimbly and quickly and
traditional school systems have been
like luxury liners if you want to turn
that thing around it takes forever and a
day and so
for us whether it's an infringement on
autonomy at least we're having
conversations that leads us down the
path to like be cognizant of it to
define it and then figure out if it's
best for the collective of schools
versus just you know turning into that
luxury line again so i think we'll
continue to be like Swift boats and be
able to make these nimble decisions but
we'll be able to do it as a whole and we
will police ourselves on that what is
one thing that you personally do on a
regular basis in your job that other
superintendents don't do I meet with a
lot of different stakeholders I probably
meet with critics as much as I do
support us because I really want to get
that information and that feedback to
really help us leverage all of our
resources in order to better serve kids
and so I think more than anything the
majority of my time is meeting with
stakeholders meeting with school leaders
meeting with community group organizers
meeting with students at times to make
certain that I stay grounded in the
everyday operations of schools so
therefore when our team is working
together we can make in foreign policies
and I think another thing that I do I
encourage my teams to stay in schools
like if we don't constantly go to
schools and really be at Ground Zero to
see what's happening every day you know
we can't make good decisions as
policymakers because we're too far
removed and we're only acting on what we
think we know versus what we know we
know are there any schools left toward
the valedictorian can't pass state
standards not at this time there thanks
very much for speaking with us thank you
for having me appreciate it for reason
TV I'm Katherine Maggie ward with
Patrick debarred of the Louisiana
recovery school district
you